habe ich so nie getrunken deswegen habe
ich auch mitgenommen dafür ist einfach
probieren bitte hier
jetzt hofft dass toni getrunken nein
habe ich nicht jedem kindergeburtstag
bei mir ist ja cool leute was geht ab
und jetzt willkommen beim neuen video ja
seit ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
ich war letztens mal in bielefeld
unterwegs und wir waren ja ziemlich
zufällig im toy stories keine ahnung wie
wir da gelandet sind aber es hat uns
irgendwie rein gezogen und ich fand ein
paar sachen will ich cool auch wenn ich
eigentlich total aus der zielgruppe raus
bin
aber wir haben hier in köln auch um die
ecke sondern laden und da fahren wir
jetzt hin und kaufen einfach mal 400
euro ein und probieren dass diese video
der ist irgendwie total spontan
entstanden also fragt euch nicht her wie
dumm ist das denn jetzt eigentlich ist
es echt dumm aber ich bin mal gespannt
was wir so film werden ich war so
natürlich möglichst viel für 100 euro zu
kaufen vielleicht werden im endeffekt
auch noch 80 also soviel geld will ich
jetzt nicht liegen lassen aber wir sehen
uns bis gleich willst du nicht okay das
ist juli will nicht so gern aufs video
heute bei ich weiß noch ganz genau
früher das war absolut mein lieblings
laden und ich war da so gerne und ich
war da bestimmt schon 15 jahre nicht
mehr drin
ja ich war vor einer woche das letzte
mal zwei drittel stimmt aber davor wenig
wie seit 12 jahren nicht gibt es das
überhaupt schon so lange also bis gleich
wir sind da wo leute das erste teil habe
ich schon und zwar so knete bobbycar amg
gt3 juli weißt du was wie wird sich das
jetzt als ferrari holen und mitfahren
[Applaus]
ein alter kumpel nichts gelernt
heute schaue ich mal hier die ganzen
autos an
[Musik]
so leute wir haben jetzt insgesamt für
ungefähr 130 euro eingekauft da sollten
wir das schöne toys'r'us hat eine menge
spaß gemacht und viele sachen kann ich
noch von früher
wir fahren jetzt erst mal nach hause wir
sind jetzt hier zu hause nicht morgen
wollte gestern zu spät war und wir haben
uns gedacht kommen wir noch mal ein
spiel zu müssen mein mitbewohner juni
wir machen das jetzt folge fasst
insgesamt für 125 euro also auf jeden
fall
30 und haben zusammen für über 130 euro
eingekauft und wir werden das jetzt so
machen gewerbe gesagt erst bei mir auch
schon schnell einmal auspacken und dann
im zweiten teil juli auf dem channel
dessen von weißt du wie schwämme das
gefallen ist ich wollte jetzt jetzt
schon mit den sachen spielt man ja wort
man kann zwar haben wir hier einmal so
eine riesen tüte mit ziemlich vielen
sinsheim und knetet das über alle
einzelnen meint ein anderes stehen die
konstanz um das ist dass kinder
überraschung für mich gekauft
wieso vier stück sogar und das seit 193
gekostet was keiner sitzgewinn das ist
weil sich eine geschichte des
wettbewerbers besonderes nehme den
figuren ist es heute das war das
allererste was ich gekauft habe und zwar
ist das kann ja auch mal aufs neue
und zwar dann handelt sich hierbei um
knetet die man verfolgen kann dann tut
man den backofen und dann bleibt die
haare aber was ist schon scheiße ist das
schockt ja gar nicht dann kann es ja gar
nicht mitverfolgen wie schwer es ist das
zu verfolgen was ist der größte
möglichkeit und das hat sieben euro
gekostet
[Musik]
ich habe das ding dagegen geworfen hat
die sonne davon 2 ich hab nur eins das
möchte wer kennt diese teile einfach mal
mitgenommen für den eigenbedarf genauso
wie die hier leute die haben wir so
schlimm kauft das probieren wir gleich
bei juni aus deswegen ist jetzt mal zur
seite
doch melt guck mal wasser das ist das
habe ich gekauft und zwar haben wir hier
so habe ich jetzt endlich geklappt hat
ich habe richtig bock auf sub morgens
deswegen habe ich mir erst mal den ich
habe so etwas noch nie getrunken das war
habe ich so nie tun deswegen habe ich
auch mitgenommen da vielleicht einmal
probieren wir hier als hast du das noch
nie getrunken
nein habe ich nicht jedem
kindergeburtstag bei mir
ich kann mir richtig gut vorstellen dass
mit harten alkohol zu mischen
okay leute und jetzt kommission in
sachen die uns wirklich tief in den
geldbeutel gegriffen haben bei diesem
über klar sollte ja die sind schon gut
also ich bin ja mal gespannt hier vor
allem auf meinen ferngesteuertes etwas
ich würde sagen wir fangen wir mit den
fenstern oder sie haben diesen hamster
gesehen der löwen mussten wir etwas
mitnehmen heißt der 30 euro je 22 also
der kann irgendwas aber wir haben nicht
gesagt wir warten entweder wird das
video ja ich glaub schon eine richtig
drauf was bekommen wir wollen manfred
setzen
wer von euch kennen noch manfred leute
das ist so schade das video zu dem das
haben so viele gar nicht gesehen wir
haben den benziner rhein gekippt dann
hat der feuer gespuckt ich verlege ich
das auf jeden fall meiner video
beschreibung ja ganz toll dass du den
geholt hat wir kommen jetzt die nächsten
sache und zwar meine welttour
[Musik]
das musste ich einfach mitnimmt
ich wollte so ein ding haben was gegen
rennes erfahren kann und sich darum
dreht aber das war mir das zu teuer
wir können dann dürfte man gruppe ist
dass kinder heutzutage ferngesteuerte
autos haben wir haben uns im
kindergarten haben alle auf dem handy
ferngesteuerte sagt ich habe mich im
chinagarten damals zu übelsten auch das
gemacht wird dass sie das noch
heute schaut mal die haben das einfach
festgeschraubt das wird nicht so
festgetackert oder wird so kabelbindern
gemacht sondern geschraubt so leute die
haben wir einmal die frage wie das hier
ausgeht also das rennauto probieren wir
auch bei julius brauchen wir noch
batterien was weiß hier sind auch ganz
ohne scheu etwas übertrieben geiles für
die bude geholt ich wollte das immer
schon haben
ich finde es zu klein halo ist fast voll
geld auf den tisch
egal was ich so hochwertig sondern die
kleinen kinder können damit spielen
wissen da viel zu groß für guck dir das
an mit überhaupt für alles viel zu groß
so der rh kritisch die folgendermaßen
aus einer xxl ja ist doch cool und jetzt
gibt mir die arbeit muss ich das ganze
aus wenn es fertig ist werden wir auch
mal juli aus dass wir jetzt erstmal hier
stehen das hat euch gleich auf jeden
fall in seinem verband und zu guter
letzt haben wir zwei sind gleich
hinterher
aber sehen so ähnlich aus damit kann man
auf jeden fall rum schießen
darauf freue ich mich schon sehr über
die macht und garantiert richtig chaos
in der wohnung sollte damit wir jetzt
wenigstens auch mal was von den sachen
testen jedoch im video habe ich mir
gedacht okay wir machen jetzt eine macht
und ein kleines nachbarduell du musst
aber vorsichtig sein
die sache gefährlich unterschätzt dass
ich das hier ist ganz einfach wir haben
hier diese alte schalke und ich würde
sagen wir haben jeder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
schüsse und wetter vermehrt genau dieses
trifft diese lasten der gewinnt also ich
sollte
zwei betroffene du bist vor war das
schlecht will ganz unten her natürlich
gucke ich lieber gegen wirklich
mithalten
die kunden finden der heißt es war es
nicht gekommen
ja kann man zählen lassen
du sollst keine diskreditieren der einen
hast du ja erhalten dann ein auge
zudrückt war auch nicht drin
wie sollen wir das beteiligte wenn der
druck war ja und ich haben uns aber ich
wünsche der leute das war die schnelle
challenge ich habe das ja nicht weil ja
wird das in der die ganzen sachen lassen
doch nach oben da bei dem video
wenn ihr jetzt sehen wollen wie das
ganze funktioniert oder ob es alles
funktioniert dann geht der über die
jetzt den zweiten part einfach
abschalten abonnieren und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder wahrscheinlich gibt es ein
neues knackiges wie zschau